[Music]
one of the things I am NOT is an
engineer as you'll find out very quickly
from this talk as well as from like the
last time I committed anything to
production this is not the world that I
live in I am instead an analyst I don't
really know what it says about our
profession that Jonah Hill is somehow
come to represent analysts but this is
what I do so my job is to take data and
turn it into insight help our business
make decisions those sorts of things I
am not someone who's off building
machine learning models or building data
platforms I am sort of the person who
applies things on top of that
specifically I work at a company called
mode so what mode does is we build one
of those platforms we build a tool for
data scientists and data analysts as a
bit of reference this is what it looks
like it's like got a web-based sequel
editor you can run queries you can get
results you can pass those results to an
embedded Python notebook create
dashboards create reports share those
things out it's very much designed for
folks like me to be able to build
reports and build reporting build
dashboards do analysis for other folks
around the business and so one of the
things that we discovered when we were
building this is one of the things it's
really important for building tools for
folks like me is the connotation of that
product it's important that the product
doesn't just have the functionality that
we wanted to have but it also speaks to
the customers that analysts are kind of
a finicky Bunch and we want to be able
to make sure we're serving those
customers correctly and so the things I
want to go over today is kind of coming
to y'all as the folks who are building
the futures of data tools to say these
are the favors that we as analysts are
asking of you these are the things that
we care about in the tools that we have
so a big part of our job again is to
build on top of the stuff that data
engineers like y'all provide and we want
to make sure that we can do the things
we want to do and so the way I want to
do this is
Stephen Colbert back when he was The
Colbert Report had this whole thing
about better and knowing a district make
it about better knowing and analysts so
like what is it that analysts are like
what is it defines kind of how we think
the kinds of tools that we want and not
just again in sort of we want X Y & Z
features but what are the kind of
requirements and in the connotations of
the products that we use that make the
one successful versus the ones that
aren't before kind of getting into the
weeds of this too much one quick kind of
bit of housekeeping I'm going to use the
words analysts and data scientists
interchangeably to some people that will
be very offensive I don't care it's
something that that people don't have
clear definitions for these things I'm
referring to folks who are using data to
be able to find insights about their
business this isn't necessarily the
folks who are off building machine
learning models and those sorts of
things there's a lot of overlap and sort
of blurry lines between these these
different kind of professions but when I
talk about this here I'm mostly talking
about the folks who are trying to find
business insight and change the way
businesses behave based on those
insights so to frame this entire
conversation I want to use this Maslow's
hierarchy of needs for analysts so this
is a sort of a famous psychological
construct about what we as humans need
so like what is it that we as analysts
need what are the things that move us up
this pyramid as analysts so to start us
off what's at the bottom of this what do
we need to do our jobs so these are some
of the things that like these are these
psychological needs these are
physiological needs rather these are
some of the things that folks are
probably familiar with Bo don't want to
run through some of those pieces and so
if you were to kind of google this and
just say like hey what is it that an
analyst or a data scientist is like you
kind of see this sort of Venn diagram a
lot like this is something that gets
passed around a good bit of like this is
what makes up a data scientist they're
people who know engineering and have
engineering skills they're people who
have some business expertise and there
are people that are familiar with
statistics so these are kind of the the
basis of these physiological needs to
some extent one of those things is data
engineering so like how much of data
engineering is actually on this base
layer for a lot of analysts again not
necessarily for the folks who are
building data engineering pipelines but
for a lot of
folks like me date engineering is it's
like the engine of a car it's something
that we rely on it's something we're
counting on but it's not necessarily
something we spend a lot of time
thinking about we want it to work but we
don't actually want to get into the the
nuts and bolts of how it works a lot of
times we are consumers of that product
not necessarily people who were in the
weeds of how it how it all works so I'm
sort of no offense to date engineers
this is a Prius engine I'm sure it's a
much more powerful engine that most
folks are building so what other things
are fitting on this so c-cool there was
already the the last talk had a lot
talking about sequel sequel is a very
foundational thing for most analysts
it's very hard to to really do your job
as analysts out having sequel in two
ways one it's the it opens the door for
the data that you're actually using that
as an analyst most of the data you
access lives behind something that
speaks sequel or something that looks
like sequel this is typically the entry
point for the work that we want to do it
also is kind of the entry point for much
deeper tools so for a lot of folks who
come into analytics from other careers
from things like consulting or sort of
MBA type roles a lot of those folks are
coming from Excel sequel is kind of the
gateway drug to more technical tools
like Python and R and other things so so
sequel is a very important thing for a
lot of analysts this is a much less
insightful chart compared to the one
from the last slide but if you just like
look at job listings for analysts and
data scientists on Glassdoor
sequel is way more popular than these
other things as a result we as analysts
do kind of crazy stuff with it if you
see what we do it's like great we use it
for analysis or data mining or data
science or machine learning so like
people try to do a lot of stuff with
sequel that may not necessarily be
obvious some people also do math with it
another thing about sequel is that
there's a lot of parts of it that we
sort of don't necessarily know a lot
about much like data engineering in
general we care about using as a tool we
don't necessarily care about the inner
workings of it group-by is an
interesting thing that that obviously if
you're familiar with sequel it's
something that's really important like
you basically can't do any sort of
analysis with it most analysts have no
clue how it works it's just a thing that
you stick on the bottom that you know it
has to be there you know how to use it
but like what does it do why is it a
like why do you have to do
it's not really a question that we often
ask and so for a lot of analysts this is
the way that we apply our tools we won't
understand how they work to get the job
done but we're not digging that deeply
into the inner workings of it so you can
see like if you ask what does group I do
you get these kind of tautological
answers of like you use it for
aggregates like what does that mean I
have no idea another thing that that
sort of as an output of data engineering
that analysts care a ton about is user
friendly data this is the thing that I
think is fairly obvious but often goes
wrong when folks are building data for
analysts but don't necessarily have sort
of the connotations of what those
analysts are trying to do so to show
some examples of that say you've got
this table here of all these different
things and it kind of looks like okay
this might be pretty good but there's
lots of things like little things in
this that go wrong that caused a lot of
pain for analysts and can make analysts
frustrated with the tool or pipeline or
data that you're building so for
instance there are these three time
stamps you may think great this is a
much richer data set it explains when
this record was created as well as when
the actual nightmare in this case
started these are two different things
it's important to have those time stamps
for analysts we often just don't know
what this means we end up looking at
this and like I'm not sure it's one of
the use I'll use one somebody else uses
another as a result we get very
different results not sure why just
because these things aren't that clear
another thing that that happens
sometimes it's a kind of simple problem
that you think I never do that but
people do is people will name columns
things like timestamp which in a lot of
database is a reserved word and if you
write select timestamp from my nightmare
you get an error because it'll be like
you can't use timestamp as a column name
another thing folks will do is they'll
put periods in column names it ends up
resulting the same thing this sequel
query doesn't work either because you
can't have periods in column names so it
slots these sort of little usability
things that don't seem like big problems
but when you're an analyst writing a
bunch of queries every day these are the
sorts of things that are that are
immensely frustrating and hold you back
from doing your job
other things like this this is
repetitive dream or something I don't
even remember what this was when I wrote
it but that's the problem with it people
have these column names that aren't well
described it's hard to figure out what
it means
again as an analyst you have a hard time
actually consuming that data and then
finally
times things are all named in all caps
as a result you end up writing a bunch
of queries like that you spend a bunch
of time staring at a text editor that
has all these all caps and then it just
feels like everything you're doing is
yelling at you it's not a big deal it's
the sort of things that like small
things that week will complain about but
it's the small things that drive us away
from one tool into another one so
another thing on this this sort of
bottom layer of expertise or
physiological needs is business
expertise so how much do we as analysts
actually have business expertise about
solving business problems again kind of
go back to the previous slide I mean
that previous slide previous talk MBAs
are actually not very important at all
so if you think about like the formal
definition of business expertise for
most analysts it's not something that we
have we're not folks coming from a lot
of places where we talk about the things
that typical MBAs would talk about most
analysts are coming from other
backgrounds that don't necessarily have
that kind of experience there's a lot
more PhDs for instance than than MBAs
and in this field final thing on that
that kind of in diagram was statistics
how much is statistics actually play a
role in our job if you think about like
sort of the stereotypical way that you
think of a data analyst it's people who
are very interested in things like
statistics you end up with questions
like this like I want to be an analyst
but I want to sit in front of a screen
and do equations all day statistics is a
little bit of an interesting thing for
most folks who are analysts I compare it
to the way that like algorithms are for
engineers you ask an engineer like do
you write algorithms most people like no
that's not at all what an engineer does
though there are a few folks who are
very specialized in that field there are
a few folks who do actually write
algorithms all day in the same way that
there are analysts that work in
statistics all day and are like very
deep in the theoretical side of
statistics most of us are not most of us
use it as just a tool to get the job
done a tool to answer questions but
we're not people who are who are like
deeply aware of all the different things
that you can do in it so for instance
one example of that is if you're someone
who focuses primarily on things like a
bee testing an optimization you're very
deep in this world you understand a lot
of different things about different
statistical models that you could apply
to different a/b tests different way to
try to forecast when in maybe tests
things like that but for a lot of us
this isn't the
world that we work in we instead work in
a world like this where we're looking at
this chart that's got active users for
some some business people come to us and
say like hey what's going on with this
chart why are active users down and the
last thing we can say is like well don't
worry about it it's not statistically
significant like we can't apply
statistics - hey the business is falling
apart and say don't worry about it like
that's not really what the problem here
is the problem is we want to understand
what's happening and we want to be able
to actually answer that question and
explain hey this is the behavior we're
seeing not turn it into a theoretical or
academic problem so to move on to the
next level of this pyramid what is it
that stresses us out like what are the
things that cause if those are the base
things we need what are the things that
make analysts stressed so that is this
safety and security pyramid layer one
thing that may be obvious for folks is
how fast stuff runs so this is a place
where we very much appreciate data
engineers the faster our queries go the
much happier we are the slower we go
that much more stressed we get why is
this because we write a ton of queries
so mode like I mentioned in the
beginning is a platform for analysts we
have a bunch of people running millions
of queries through our platform every
day on average an analyst writes 160
queries a day so we're sitting around
writing these things it's a ton of
queries those queries take on average
about 20 seconds to run if you do the
basic math here that means we're sitting
around waiting for queries to run for
about 53 minutes a day so it's a lot of
time to just sit around and wait it's a
lot of time for us to either feel the
pain of things moving really slow or to
be excited when something finishes
quickly so that's one of those things
where as data engineers as people
thinking about the kinds of stuff that
analysts care about are your customers
care about just being able to make
things go fast makes a huge difference
for us another way that we care the
things we care a lot about is why data
changes so again we're not necessarily
like in the inner workings of what the
pipelines look like but if something
comes out the other end that looks
different than it did yesterday that's
the kind of thing that causes a lot of
stress and causes us to go down a bunch
of rabbit holes to figure out what
happened so for instance say we come
along and
like right select star from users today
and we've got these two users and then
we come along tomorrow and Gaston has
been deleted and the Beast is gone it's
very confusing it's what happened and
like our results now have to change we
have to go back and say like what
happened to our analysis why is our
results different this is the sort of
thing that that sins analysts down a lot
of rabbit holes and puts us in a place
where we have to like rework problems
that we've already solved and so if
there are ways I actually don't know of
a good way that people solve these sorts
of problems for you to be able to
understand like how is data change and
those sorts of things but if there ways
to solve this problems again this saves
us a ton of time and a ton of headache
about like what's going on and the
results that we found another thing that
analysts are often stressed about is
things like git and github and sort of
the the fringe of the technical skills
that we are supposed to have but don't
necessarily have as much as perhaps we
should so this is how a lot of analysts
and by a lot of analysts people like me
use git will be like cool let's could
commit something we've done some
analysis we've sort of changed our basic
motto we'll do this sort of stuff we
actually forgot to pull it and then
we're like okay git pull no no try it
again try it again do it again I don't
know like that pseudo get pull I don't
know still didn't work all right start
all over it's like this is kind of the
experience that we have with some of
these things and don't even get me
started on merge conflicts I have no
idea what you're supposed to do with a
merge conflict we can figure this out
but again it's the kind of thing where
this isn't really the domain of what
analysts do we want to be we know it's
like the place to uplevel ourselves and
that analytics is becoming more and more
technical and more and more of an
engineering field but to the extent that
that we can be enabled by the tools to
learn that and to be educated in that
that's something that can can save us a
lot of stress another place again that
causes some anxiety is sequel we use it
all the time
but as a result we find a lot of weird
things that it does so for instance say
you go back to having this table and you
write this query like great that works
now you get rid of the comma now it
doesn't work because it shouldn't now
let's replace that column with a column
that doesn't exist that works now
you do this or like I don't understand
any these columns are you run that that
works so sequel does some weird stuff if
you want to like talk to people about
weird nerdy things about sequel talk to
your neighborhood analyst so yeah so
this is a place again where we're
sequels a powerful tool but but there's
some lack of clarity and it would go a
long way for us to to be able to use it
more effectively as well another thing
it's a little bit more trivial that
causes analysts a lot of stress if you
ever want to start a fight with a bunch
of analysts ask them how they format
their sequel some people do this that's
okay some people do this that's terrible
sane people do this some people do it
like all in one line if people have like
very passionate about the way they do
this we actually at mode just released a
feature that encouraged a particular
type of formatting it was very well
received by some people and not at all
well-received by others so yeah this is
a place where again we we stress out
about things that perhaps we shouldn't a
little bit more of a serious note a
thing that it also is a place that gives
analysts trouble is answering what
should be simple questions so a good
example of this is you probably if
you're working for a business you want
to know how much money do we make ah it
seems pretty basic it seems important
it's just like add up the number of
bills that people are paying you and
you're done
in reality typically being able to
answer that question requires you to go
through some chart like this of like was
it a trial was it did it get cancelled
will was it a test account was it a cap
that only paid partially what happens if
the credit card got declined all this
data was entered by humans what happens
it was in and wrong these are the sorts
of things that a lot of our work is done
trying to solve is answer these simple
questions these simple questions that
end up being very complicated because of
how the data is structured because of
how the business is structured and the
sense the way that we can like abstract
this away saves us a lot of headache as
well our ability to be able to to answer
what it's simple or to be given data
that sort of handles a lot of this for
us can make analyst much more effective
at answering with the deeper level
questions that that were more motivated
to answer similarly another thing that
that probably gives analysts more stress
than anything is when a dashboard goes
down so again
turning to this chart as soon as this
happens what happens is some executive
will come to you and be like what in the
world happened why are we losing users
figure it out and some cases it's easy
to find the answer it's like oh we
shipped a bad app that the signup flow
is broken that it's a holiday somewhere
in other cases it's like trying to chase
why the stock market went down
you have no idea it's just a bunch of
noise if there again places for us to be
able to point to being able to do these
these sorts of like diving into these
really hard problems that don't really
have an answer we spend a lot of time
going down these rabbit holes to try to
understand what it sometimes noise and
what it sometimes no one as an aside
analysts often have or at least ones
that work in SAS businesses that are b2b
a lot of knowledge of international
holidays because those tips are often
caused by international holidays and
like the Netherlands somewhere and takes
you a while to figure that out so for
instance at mode we have this reference
of international holidays that we can
check against any time we see a dip like
that the last thing here that that again
gives us anxiety is change and it's not
just change in the data but it's
changing the structure of the data or
changing the structure of the business
that will build analyses will build sort
of the way that we want to do things
this is how we do our reporting this is
the way we define revenue in that very
complicated way and then something about
the business changes either the way that
we sell changes or the way that we
report it changes or we decided we want
to report in a slightly different way
and this happens all the time and so we
want our tools to be flexible to this as
an example of this so this is again mode
is being connected to a lot of people's
data we could see how often schemas
change in people's database and on
average they change about once every
five hours and so that's the level of
change that analysts are having to work
against it's not a static model that we
build everything on top of and then once
every quarter there's some big business
change these things are constantly
evolving as new marketing campaign
campaigns go out as new like sort of
sales processes go out as new products
are shipped and so we have to be
constantly reacting to those changes all
right so moving up again so the third
level in this this pyramid is the the
belonging the feeling of like social
belonging so how is the
let's connect to other people we're not
always like the most social bunch so how
do we go about doing it so one way is
presenting our work this is a huge thing
that that tools need to enable us to do
that analysts don't make charts and
dashboards for the sake of making charts
and dashboards they do it to share it
with other people and so much of what
we're trying to do of all of these
things of like collecting data storing
data manipulating it modeling and
analyzing it visualizing it all of that
is aimed at trying to communicate it and
help other people understand and so so
much of the interaction that we have is
through the the work that we communicate
we have to work with folks a lot as well
but a lot of the things we're trying to
do is distribute our work around the
organization to the people who need to
make decisions based on it and so tools
that don't enable this our tools that
really constrain analysts to be more
inward focusing rather than outward
focusing which is makes them effective
as a business another thing that that
analysts will do to communicate a lot
and if you've ever talked to an analyst
you probably noticed this they
communicate a lot in analogies
there's actually I think a reason for
this that a lot of what analysis is is
sort of stripping out complexity from a
problem taking it down to like a
skeleton and mapping that on to some
other skeleton that you can more easily
understand this is basically what
analogies are and so a lot of times when
analysts are talking to folks they'll
put together these sort of simple mental
models if this is how the world works
this is how I would explain this problem
and so you see this all the time there's
actually this really nice Paul Krugman
quote about this that these sort of
things are really powerful that that I
mean I very much believe this but I
think this is something that deserves a
lot of credit for people to be able to
communicate in this sort of way that
being able to take something complicated
strip out the complexity again and turn
it into this really intuitive story goes
a long way and explaining these
complicated concepts another way that we
as analysts often will we'll work with
other folks is by trying to understand
the things that people are asking that a
lot of times analysts are seen as sort
of a consulting agency within a company
they're seen as a service arm where
people go to them with questions they
say hey can I get this data can you help
me understand this problem can you let
me understand some part of my business
when that happens if you come along and
say hey like why are active users
dipping you may think hey there
spots here is like here is bullet one
bullet two blip three-four why typically
the annal the answer you'll get from an
analyst is like why the point of that
isn't necessarily to push back it's not
to be difficult but it's to try to
understand hey there's lots of different
ways to answer this question how can we
most effectively answer that question
for the problem that you're trying to
solve I kind of the the double edge sort
of this is there's a lot of like bedside
manner in this that analysts also aren't
very good at a lot of times where it
does seem confrontational and doesn't
always seem like it's a productive
asking why it seems like it's more
pushing back this is something that like
we'll work on I don't have any clever
slides for why in the world we're bad at
this okay so what about at the top of
this pyramid like once we get above kind
of the basics this is what our job is
what is it that actually makes analysts
feel successful and this is I think what
separates the successful tools or the
successful teams from the ones that are
sort of just doing the job so that is
this this fourth X team pyramid so this
is like what makes analysts analysts is
a lot of times people who are who are in
data fields if you go out and talk to
somebody who's not at all in the space
they'll assume you do it because you
want to work with data you'll play
fantasy football gonna be like great
it's the data guy he's gonna like crunch
a bunch of numbers that draft his team
analysts aren't really in this for the
data alone most people are in it because
they're interested in what the data
tells them the point is it like I love
numbers the point is it's interesting to
understand how the world works and data
is a really compelling way to figure
that out that this book is one of the
most popular books I know among people
who who do the things that I do it's a
book by Christian rudder about how
people interact with each other on
OKCupid it is not something filled with
a bunch of complicated analyses it's not
something filled with like super
technical content it's something filled
with a bunch of interesting questions
about how people behave and some data
that shows that this is the way they do
it so like that is ultimately a lot of
things that's driving analysts to be
what they are is to just answer these
questions about how the world works so
some examples of the sorts of things
that I think people on our team at mode
have been really interested in just like
lunch table kind of conversations that
makes analysts sort of excited and fired
up is like I wonder whether or not
weather affects election turnout which
it turns out it only does in
non-competitive elections people
wondering I wonder what happens if icing
the kicker works it mostly doesn't
though that's kind of disputed people
wondering if younger founders are more
successful in tech companies it turns
out they are not and people wondering if
West Virginia is in the south and it
turns out it is most people think so
unless you're from West Virginia and
then nobody thinks so so these are the
sorts of things that really motivate
analysts again it's not like I want to
go play with numbers is that I want to
answer these kind of interesting
questions about how the world works and
have a better understanding of my
environment my company or just kind of
the world at large because of it part of
that and part of what that extends into
is analysts are also very interested in
caveats and nuance this can be a
frustrating thing if you're engaging
with one because they won't necessarily
say things in strict terms there's a lot
of suggests and indicates and points to
but the reason people do that is because
analysts again want to be able to
explain the world and describing the
world is often a complicated thing it's
not a it's not always a clean story it's
something that has complexity it has
uncertainty and so like if people were
following along with the election
coverage 538 publishes this like fairly
complicated chart for this was their
prediction right before the election
about where things would settle in the
house people if you sort of looked at
their their Twitter comments which is
probably a dangerous place to be people
are complaining like just say what's the
number how many seats are they going to
win what is your forecast why can't you
just like stand on a forecast and say
that's it and that's not representation
of the way the world works that analysts
want to introduce this complexity and
this is kind of uncertainty in it
because they're trying to more
accurately portray the world and so when
we communicate work again either
publicly or in a business setting we
want to try to do it in this sort of way
we want to try to represent it
accurately rather than just saying hey
this is going to work or there
definitely isn't going to work so then
what's at the very top what is it
ultimately that sort of fulfills us as
analysts if this is the stuff that makes
it successful these are the things we
want to do what are the things that that
like give us a nerdy analyst hi
when we can actually do them and so a
big one is understanding why it's not
just about understanding the world but
it's understanding why the world behaves
the way it does and if you think about
like what data is and kind of even where
like statistics came from a lot of this
was around the framework that data tells
an objective truth that the way the
world works can be described in data
that's all you need and that's the
that's the Providence of machines for
analysts we don't necessarily see it
that way that that understanding
causality and causal inference is
something that isn't just in the world
of machines it requires something that's
much more creative it requires a much
sort of higher level of thinking that
goes into understanding relationships in
the world that aren't obvious in data
and understanding what counterfactuals
might be out there and having the
imagination and creativity to explore
these problems and think about what
would the data look like if these things
were true these aren't things that you
can necessarily plug into to even the
most complicated like machine learning
models or neural networks and get
answers to they are things that require
what is at this point only human
reasoning and being able to answer those
questions is the sort of thing that
analysts are really driving towards like
understanding not just what does this
data say and what are these
relationships but why is the world
behaving that way as if you were
interested this there's this really
interesting book so this is a causal
diagram today a purl is kind of one of
the foremost thinkers and this he
recently had a book called the book of Y
which gets into like why this kind of
causal thinking is something that is
still well beyond what machines and data
science can do and he was the person who
first developed the neural network so
he's not coming from it from a
perspective of like hating on the
technology it's just that technology
doesn't yet replace what this like why
question is that analyst so desperately
want to answer the the second piece of
this I think that is one of the most
important parts of an analyst job and
one of the ones that again is kind of at
the peak top of this pyramid is telling
a story about what this data says that
that as analysts we don't see our job is
to ship off data to other folks and say
hey here you go figure out what this
means here's a dashboard here's a report
here's some insight and now you go
figure out like where to take it a big
part of the
we do what we do is to try to drive
behavior and help people understand and
change the things they do because of
that that that analysis isn't there's a
handoff it's part of a storytelling
process to be able to say this is the
way the world works this is how we
interpret it this is how we think things
should change and then you want to
follow through on that to see if we were
right and so I think one of the ways you
see this is if you look at the people
who aren't necessarily the best data
scientists in the world but are some of
the best storytellers in the world this
is how they do it so if you look at the
types of graphics and data
visualizations the New York Times does
even though the visualizations
themselves are incredible and can very
much stand on their own they never do
the New York Times always just tries to
say let's put story with it let's put a
narrative to this let's tell people what
they're looking at help them understand
it and guide them to how to explore it
on their own rather than just present
these really rich visualizations by
themselves and if the visualization is
the New York Times creates which are way
better than anything people would create
and companies aren't good enough to
stand on their own then types of
dashboards that we as analysts would
build rarely would be able to as well so
what does that mean what do we want from
like data engineers what do we want in
our tools what are the things that were
really after as analysts and kind of
this ecosystem basically there's like
going back to this pyramid the things at
the bottoms are the things that sort of
like are the table stakes there are the
things that make us choose a tool or not
choose a tool because we have to do the
things that were like if we can't do
sequel for instance and a lot of cases
it's like well that's a blocker for us
because we have to get access to data
but really the things that drive us to
choose something versus not is how well
does it affect us on these top layers
it's the things that help us actually do
the things that make us feel proud of
what our job is and answer the questions
that we're sort of intrinsically
motivated to answer rather than the ones
that just like do the job and that's it
so to make that a little bit more
concrete what does that mean it means as
analysts we want to use technology we
don't want to be prescribed it we don't
wanna be told we have to use this or
this we want to use whatever technology
is most flexible for the challenge we're
trying to answer it also means that data
should be created for humans not
machines we are the consumers
this data that we are the customers of a
lot of like data engineers in product
and want to feel like those customers we
want to be able to take that data and
understand this is for us and this is
for people to interact with not strictly
for machines to interact with we want to
express complexity we want tools that
enable us to show how complicated the
world is and be able to communicate that
expects 'ti rather than having to hide
it and rather than having to just say
the answer is yes the answer is no the
answer is higher the answer is lower we
want to be flexible to change and not
something that's undone by it so tools
that are rigid tools that don't like
respond to to a very quickly changing
world tools that don't respond to
changing data infrastructures tools that
don't respond to changing businesses are
tools that again are very challenging
and can be frustrating we want tools
that can lean into that kind of change
rather than tools that that are making
assumptions that that's not going to
happen and finally we want tools that
can help us share the stories of what
data tells and the why behind it not
just a tool that lets us say this is
what the data says that again so much of
what our job is what motivates us to be
analysts and and to work on these sorts
of problems is being able to tell why
and being able to be a part of that
storytelling process rather than just
people who are curating dashboards or
curating numbers for other people to
consume or interpret on their own so the
last bit of this to close on an analogy
because that's what we do the way that
I've always thought of this is that
ultimately as analysts the tools that we
want are tools like radio towers there
are things that we want to be able to
put up when we have a question and want
to be able to get somewhere we want to
build to build it very quickly and very
tall very quickly want to explore
problems of like great depth very very
quickly we don't want to have to build
this kind of slow building monument that
we slowly build up to hard questions we
want to be able to go from the ground to
a very hard question and answer very
quickly and then if we find an answer we
find something interesting there we can
go figure out where that takes us and
build another radio tower on top of that
question rather than again having to go
and kind of build something up from the
bottom very slowly we want to be able to
these very quick explorations figure out
what's interesting figure out what's
going on in the world figure out why and
then and then be able to communicate it
and I
Hatton honestly even thought of this
part of the analogy until just now we're
gonna go to broadcast it out much like
you could in radio tower so that is what
I've got questions
[Applause]
or software development things like
yes so I think that that analysts need
to be better at at technical skills that
that get example is something that like
analysts need to be overcome and and I
very much agree with DB T's philosophy
that like the especially the sort of
final mile of data data pipelines are
better off left to analysts who are the
ones actually consuming that data that
much to the point the second one that
analysts are the ones who are the
customers of that data to the extent
that they can also be the creators of it
it enables them to be much more
effective so yeah I think like the git
piece isn't necessarily saying hey we
shouldn't have to learn that it's more
we should but how can we help like how
can tools help us get there rather than
just saying hey go learn this thing the
other the other side of that the one
place where I would sort of take a a
slight disagreement with some of the
things that I think the way the DBT
Express is is so I don't believe
analytics is like a subset of software
engineering that the problems that
analysts solve and a lot of these other
things on this slide require a very
different way of thinking than the way
that engineers think it's just a
different kind of problem that what
makes a great analyst is their ability
to be creative in the way they think
about like asking questions of data the
ability to like ask counterfactuals and
those sorts of things I think a lot of
those skills also apply to software
engineering but it's not necessarily the
same thing it's sort of a sister
profession rather than one that is sort
of a subset
I mean I'm biased I think mode does a
decent job of it but part of that is is
just giving you that so so as a very
simple case one of the things that mode
does so Python notebooks are good
example this too
one of things that mode does that
notebooks do and you can also do in
something like our markdown is it gives
you the ability to add like narration it
gives you the ability not just to
present a dashboard and then leave kind
of the interpretation up to the person
who's consuming it it gives you the
ability to point something out and say
hey I looked at this chart and it told
me that something was going on here so I
investigated this turns out it wasn't
that I then investigated this it turns
out like there's some leads in that so
part of it is is just not expecting
people to have to come up with that all
of their own from just looking at a
chart it's being able to like describe
those stories as they consume it so
again I think that's why I like the New
York Times is a good example that they
never leave it up to you entirely they
let you explore it if you want and say
you can go deep but we're not gonna like
make you figure out what you're supposed
to come away from this yes I have no
idea sounds like it alright so a bit of
a comment and then a question sure so
we've actually taken that the answer to
simple question which i think is really
important we sort of flipped it on its
head so the system that we've built one
of the goals is to actually pre answer
all of those simple questions and put
them in front of the people who actually
should know what those answers are and
so really what you end up with is this
sort of checksum where you've cut the
data across many dimensions and then
integrated it up and put a number in
front of somebody who has a pretty good
idea of what that is and it's a way of
sort of building confidence and faith in
the underlying system see we've actually
had a lot of success with that and it's
really we find it's a really good
high-level way that figuring out if
anything has become inconsistent in a
way that as a data engineer
full-disclosure data engineer that we
might not actually know do you have any
suggestions from the analyst side of
things like that that can help data
engineers sort of build faith and
interest in the systems that that
they're that they're building and that
that the data has integrity that
things that date engineers can use to
sort of check the integrity of their
data yeah yeah so yeah so I think an
example of this where where we've seen
this come up not necessarily with the
consumption from analysts but from other
people in the business and it this sort
of trickles down to analysts is
businesses will start on Google
Analytics you're a five person company
you're like we want to see how many
people are looking at our website let's
use Google Analytics we have a number we
get 5,000 people a day we didn't say we
want to migrate to something else it's
time to move on to a tool that can do a
lot more and they'll then migrate to
some other platform they'll now say we
get 4,800 people a day there's lots of
reasons for that difference that the way
Google computes sessions might be
different it might be counting something
slightly differently like tracking is a
little bit different how do they do
anonymous sessions might be different
but four people are consuming that data
looking at that as like oh my god this
was one number now it's another unless
people have good answers as to why these
things are gonna change I'm never gonna
have faith in the second number that no
there's there's some like there's some
logical fallacies in that of like why
would you assume the first one is right
like you just do but but being able to
explain hey this is going to be
different or helping anticipate those
things at least from an analyst
perspective to our customers is by far
the most important thing you can do when
stuff starts to shift is like yeah like
we're on top of it not like oh god
you're right that is different let me go
dig into that so that I think is one
thing another thing is kind of similar
to what you mentioned in DBT does a good
job of this of being able to provide
what amount to like unit tests for data
to be able to just periodically run
checks of like are we recording events
that don't match our schema are we
recording like are there places where
the purchase price of this this thing
was negative ten dollars that doesn't
make any sense those sorts of things
that just be able to like find anomalies
that aren't that are sort of invalidated
not anomalies in the sense of a spike
but anomalies in the sense of like this
shouldn't exist and being able to learn
people to that provides a lot of
confidence as well
you
[Music]